les responsables d'amnesty international
confirme l'effrayante informations
qu'ils ont donné hier le massacre d'une
centaine d'enfants à bangui sur l' ordre
de l'empereur bokassa 1er les écoliers
centrafricain protestaient depuis le
début de l'année par des manifestations
contre l'obligation de porter l'uniforme
la voiture de bokassa reçu des pierres
et c'est à ce moment là le 18 avril que
la garde impériale aurait effectué une
razzia d'enfants dans quatre quartiers
de bangui des témoins l'affirment ses
enfants étaient enfermés à la prison
centrale une vingtaine d'entre eux sont
morts étouffés dans des cellules
hermétique d'autres ont été frappés à
coups de baïonnette ou lapidé par les
gardes ou encore fouetter à mort par des
bâtons cloutés les cadavres des enfants
dit encore amnesty ont été enterrés de
nuit dans une fosse commune je voulais
dit amnesty international apporte
aujourd'hui confirmation de ces faits
atroces
amnistie internationale ne diffuse en
matière d'information que ce qu'elle a
pu vérifier
alors bien sûr je vous dirais que nous
avons des preuves maintenant c'est je
peux vous dire que ces informations
viennent de différentes sources
africaines et européennes qu'elles sont
multiples et digne de foi je ne vous en
dirai pas plus pour des raisons
évidentes sécurité de des témoins
de tels actes de violence ne sont pas
rares en centrafrique déjà sa majesté
bokassa 1er alors qu'il n'était encore
que président à vie faisait couper
aurait aisément aux voleurs et exposer
les mutilés sur la place publique le
nouveau drame de bandits survient dans
un climat de contestation les
manifestations contre le régime n'ont
guère cessé depuis le couronnement de
l'empereur déjà du 19 au 22 janvier des
lycéens avaient manifesté
leurs manifestations avaient été
réprimées à coups de mortiers et avec
l'aide de militaires et irois appelés en
renfort peu après les incidents
s'étaient mises en grève parce que leurs
salaires n'étaient plus payés les arrêts
de travail s'était étendue à d'autres
secteurs en même temps le mécontentement
monte chez les planteurs de coton de la
société cotonnière d'état prétendez
payer par chèque alors que les campagnes
ne possède aucune infrastructure
bancaire
les caisses de l'état sont vides
l'inquiétude règne depuis deux mois
étudiants et lycéens désertent les
universités et des collèges la série
d'arrestations effectuées le 8 avril n'a
pas contribué à les remplir pas plus que
les événements sanglants et 17 et 18
avril
empire centrafricain un nouveau sujet
d'inquiétude pour l'afrique où trop
souvent les noirs quand ils ne sont pas
opprimées par les blancs le son par
d'autres noirs
mais je pense que en pleine année
internationale de l'enfance les
événements on vient de nous dire en
république centrafricaine contre des
enfants ce massacre des enfants
suscitera au moins pour le moins
quelques protestions quelques
protestations internationales qui ne
sont pas encore venu je vous lis